[Musica]
partiamo da ripartiamo da qua della
biodiversità ci serve ne abbiamo bisogno
che abbiamo bisogno attorno a noi
abbiamo bisogno tra di noi nella
diversità di relazioni che ci servono
ne ho bisogno dentro di noi nella nostra
pancia nel nostro intestino per il
nostro sistema immunitario per
difenderci dall'esterno
andiamo a pratico cosa avete mangiato
stamattina per colazione seguito una
dieta vegana vegetariana onnivora meno
tutte non c'è non c'è critica nella
domanda ovviamente io così l'unica cosa
che posso stimolarvi ed è quello che
farò attraverso delle immagini così non
vi do dati perché già ne avete preso
abbastanza stamattina interessantissimi
però vado per immagini
ognuno del dei tipi di dieta che vi ho
appena citato
ovviamente sostiene dei modelli diversi
crea un pezzo di di futuro completamente
diverso
io per correttezza ve lo dico sono
cresciuto in un posto così in una
fattoria poi come accennato prima ho
fatto un percorso di ho seguito un'altra
passione la comunicazione eccetera che è
stata un po un percorso lungo che mi ha
permesso di incontrare di confrontarmi
ma soprattutto di incontrare realtà e
persone incredibili il mio inizio di
reazione a parte da qua nel condividere
con voi tutte quelle cose meravigliose
e entusiasmante è estremamente
provocatori che ho incontrato in tutti
in tutti questi anni negli ultimi
soprattutto una delle critiche delle
considerazioni del domande che mi sono
arrivate più più spesso è stata ma senti
ma tutte queste ragionamenti la
sostenibilità le diete alimentare la
biodiversità
tutte queste elucubrazioni definite così
e se trama non è più semplice che
semplicemente rimettiamo tutti è la
tocca contatto con la terra che mettiamo
tutte le mani nella terra veniamo giù
con i piedi per terra c'è stata sì per
metà sono d'accordo la terra la ruralità
e ritornare a contatto con i diciamo
così coni con le dinamiche che
determinano le cose fondamentali che ci
servono primarie l'acqua il cibo che in
questo momento sono molto lontane da noi
sono separate da noi è fondamentale è
uno dico sempre la terra è uno degli
strumenti di diesel in azioni più divisi
dalle nazioni più potenti che abbiamo
ovviamente
fatto s'è fatto salvo il fatto di essere
consapevoli che siamo allenati da questi
modelli che portano ad avere l'acqua in
casa che portano avere il cibo nel
frigorifero eccetera eccetera
parlando per immagini se io vi faccio
vedere questa immagine cosa cosa vi
viene in mente disastro ambientale
qualcuno immagina questioni globali
qualcuno immagina magari si
responsabilizza un po di più
[Musica]
non lo so cose più più vicine cioè i
privilegi che che ci portano ad avere il
gasolio una macchina questo è un po una
provocazione iniziale che voglio che
voglio farvi per per arrivare al punto
che perché volevo lasciarvi un'immagine
attiva stimola cose completamente
diverse
questo è un po il titolo che ha voluto
dare prima la terra no prima
l'immaginario perché perché si
riportiamo le mani nella terra ma
l'altra metà che dicevo su quella quale
non sono d'accordo è perché abbiamo
messo l'immaginario al potere
l'immaginario che riceviamo da cui siamo
influenzati condiziona poi anche le
nostre scelte quotidiane e questo
immaginario quello che decide determina
anche se uno mi parlavi vi entusiasma vi
dice cose poi ognuno torna nella propria
vita e quello che fa capo e ancora
l'immagine nella nostra testa di provoco
con un'immagine potrei farlo anche
un'altra o caspita parla di terra cioè
finalmente le immagine bucolica voglio
dire io ho cercato questa immagine i tag
e erano felicità gioia positività a
giornata di sole giusto no ecco
l'esempio
ve l'ho portata perché questa è una
diapositiva meravigliosa di un disastro
ecologico che si ripete tutti gli anni
per produrre il grano perché disastro
ecologico che sta dicendo sto qua dias
tecnologico per la tonnellate di
diserbanti che servono per non far
comparire neanche un filo d'erba
disastro ecologico per il tipo di grano
selezionato che analizzato e crea dei
disastri incredibili nella nostra nei
nostri stomaci un disastro ecologico
perché non c'è neanche una pianta a
pagarlo a peso d'oro un km se non è in
fondo proprio ecco confessatelo non
probabilmente non era esattamente
proprio i primi pensieri avete fatto
nonostante io abbia fatto vedere questa
immagine
sotto sigilli a cesarò sibillino se io
vi faccio il contrario di questo di
queste di questo esempio vi dico
riempite il frigorifero c'è il bisogno
di riempire la dispensa che immagini
visivi si creano nella testa anche
sfocate così pronti via
qualcuno avrà immaginato questo giusto
oppure un'immagine tipo questa oppure
un'altra tipo questa come dicevo prima
per la colazione tra immagini simili
sostengono creano implementano modelli e
futuro completamente diverse una
dall'altra chi ha visto il film
inception da così mi è un po più su un
pochettino più semplice volendo
insistere volendo lasciarvi questa cosa
dell'immaginario l'innesto è quella
parte di il modo più semplice per
spiegare quanto questa questi schemi
mentali possono essere influenzati non
sono compartimenti stagni questa è la
cattiva notizia e ci sono molte persone
che hanno interesse non è dietrologia
non è complottismo che hanno interessi
economici ormai soggettivo a far sì che
noi manteniamo certi schemi mentali che
nostre vite siano all'interno di certi
schemi mentali e che sostengano e
mantengano certi modelli perché
funzionano e servono qualcuno quindi la
prova che se n'è più grande ovviamente è
legata a rompere questi modelli che
possono essere influenzati abbiamo
sentito anche prima con il cinema
antimonio la televisione con giornalismo
giustamente questo è un esempio di
quello che succede tutti i giorni anche
in sequenza rispetto anche in seguito in
conseguenza di queste di queste
influenze certificazione biologica o
sappiamo tutti è uno dei the dei grandi
temi e ci sono c'è di tutto
guerra di religione quasi tutto contro
tutto si biologico è una cosa
meravigliosa salverà il mondo è una
farsa tutto finto eccetera
ce n'è un altro di te ma così proprio
per per citarne un paio con gli ogm
anche qui da una parte dall'altra magari
effettivamente l'oggetto di queste
discussioni di questa bagarre che
succeda online offline eccetera eccetera
magari se ci pensiamo bene a volte siamo
quasi pronti a scannarci contro l'altro
in qualche modo a dicendo come se fosse
una verità conquistata in anni di vita e
quando magari ci pensavo davvero
e quasi lontano da noi l'essenza di
questa di certi concetti che cerchiamo
di difendere con le unghie e con i denti
a volte no forse la cosa migliore che
possiamo fare è fermarci e osservare un
attività rivoluzionaria perché vi faccio
vedere vi vuole provocare con questa
immagine che sta probabilmente potrebbe
essere dovrebbe essere esagero stampato
e affisso in ogni casa lo avesse il
nostro immaginario di riferimento cosa
una zolla di terra immaginaria di
riferimento ma questa di questo è il
primo strato della casa sotto i nostri
piedi el'humus cosiddetto sostanza
organica tua lento ci sono miliardi di
microrganismi ecc senza fare discorsi
scientifici una cosa molto semplice
perché dovrebbe essere di riferimento
perché questi potrebbero essere i nostri
eroi nel senso che un microrganismo
buttato nella mischia o crepa oppure
immediatamente si mette in relazione con
tutte le altre con tutti gli altri
organismi e stimola attiva dei processi
di sinergia che sono efficaci e proficui
per entrambi gli anglofoni win win
cosa che dal mio punto di vista rispetto
a tutto quello che ho visto tutto quello
che ho incontrato è una delle cose più
difficili o l'abbiamo dimenticato non so
dobbiamo imparare a farlo uno dei due
scegliamo ovviamente i sistemi sono
complessi non ci sono solo i
microrganismi ci sono anche le piante
che ognuno che svolge la sua funzione
comunque l'importante secondo me è
l'azione osservare ci sono centinaia di
esempi
ovviamente con tanti dati tanti tanti
esperimenti tante analisi tra eccetera
dove parlando di scenari entrando nello
specifico adesso questa evidentemente
non è un incontro per addetti ai lavori
evidentemente però ci sono in scenari
che sono anche facilmente comprensibili
quando ci stiamo
come si può dire a cercare soluzioni
incredibili quando a volte basta capire
in maniera anche diretta si vede è molto
comprensibile molto visibile quanto
basta su un tema come quello della
situazione di co2 intervenire
semplicemente con le coltivazioni con
l'agricoltura scenari come questi anche
qui parlando di immagini sono più in una
norma cioè coltiva uomini che coltivano
le orticole in fila sono tante va bene
ecco questo un altro esempio di disastro
nel senso per questioni di esposizione
del terreno eccetera eccetera
si può anche coltivare così matteo
doveva essere come te mazzola deve
essere qui con me sta facendo questa
operazione qua a iside sul sun e quali
non vi parlo di cose dall'altra parte
dell'universo e vi potrebbe spiegare
perché non c'è un centimetro di terra
libero scoperto scenari diversi
qui sono nella testa delle persone si
qui magari agli addetti ai lavori
potrebbe si potrebbe entrare nel merito
e spiegare e cominciare a ragionare
ma il punto è l'osservazione veramente
toglierci da da dalle cose omologate
dall'omologazione nell'immaginario
ovviamente i sistemi sono complessi non
basta non bastano le piante si può
essere anche gli animali
il sistema è sono complessità di
complessità a proposito di diversità
se fosse stato qua come aveva spiegato
molto bene si è entrato nel dettaglio di
come non sia vero parlare né di
agricoltura né di certificazioni di
sistemi sistemi integranti come dire
come piace chiamarle come piace
chiamarle matteo sistemi agro silvo
pastorali rigenerativi perché perché una
rigenerazione
la reazione in questo caso è una
rigenerazione esempio di vario tipo dove
forse la cosa interessante da osservare
è che una semplice passeggiata cloache
belle macchine che ci sono in un campo
in realtà è un complessissimo sistema
che è venuto meno in cui una cosa quasi
bucolica a come si può dire in realtà è
un sistema da riadottare da riprendere
in considerazione con tutte le sue
complessità
questo un altro scenario di riferimento
penso che a tutti vogliamo fare vogliamo
mangiare il pane perfetto di a coltivare
il grano i grandi si coltivano così non
è detto si potrebbe coltivare anche così
e vi garantisco che impatto sarebbe
tutt'altro la costruzione di un futuro
con meno problemi sarebbe tutt'altro
e importante che teniamo sempre presenti
l'ho rimessa anche in coda perché
l'importante è che ragioniamo e
osserviamo ragionare con la nostra testa
e ci mettiamo ad osservare fermi tutti
questa è un'immagine che secondo me ha
due significati
1 innanzitutto è quello di doversi
fermare a ragionare un attimo e l'altra
è quella di che non si può non si può
fare non si può fare un'operazione di
pulire immaginare di metterci in
sinergia di attivare dei processi di
sinergia finché non smontiamo uno dei
secondo me uno dei limiti uno dei
gradini più alti che abbiamo tra di noi
la diffidenza congenita io la chiamo
così non ho un altro modo per per
definirla cioè magari ci ci ci fidiamo
ci piace non siamo stati ammaliati dai
grandi gruppi che conosco il marketing a
proposito di marketing è riuscito a
entrare nel nostro cuore
amiamo desideriamo degli strumenti
magari che ci che sono dei pezzi di
controllo delle nostre vite e siamo
diffidenti con il nostro vicino cosa che
appunto i microrganismi ci guarderemo ma
questo c'è bisogno di una sinergia tra
di noi
e per fare questa cosa qua c'è bisogno
di fare un'operazione di come si può
dire di discesa dal gradino anche qui un
altro termine che ritorna del
capitalismo egoico del guardare ognuno
dentro noi stessi non voglio fare
retorica però un passaggio fondamentale
perché sono tutte le altre operazioni
il fatto di essere provocati dal punto
di vista delle dinamiche naturali è un
lavoro che non si può fare perché deve
partire dall ognuno deve partire dal
microrganismo dell'organismo 1 per poi
interagire per poi proliferare su sugli
altri con gli altri io vedo ha parato
anche un immagine come questa che perché
adesso stiamo facendo anche un progetto
territoriale appunto però ecco la prima
cosa da cui mi voglio smarcare non è
un'immagine per dire ah beh ma christian
dillo subito se sia per cambiare e
creare un futuro migliore
mi vado a fare una passeggiata e sabato
perigeo parcheggio la mia auto fuori e
ci sediamo su delle balle di paglia
no non è esattamente messaggio che vi
volevo portare c'è bisogno sicuramente
di riprogettare i territori di
riprogettare le relazioni che ci sono
sui territori ma c'è bisogno anche di
tornare a comprendere ad ascoltare ad
approfondire quelli che sono i temi che
determinano quello di cui abbiamo
bisogno abbiamo un pochino sbolognato
scusate il termine tutte le cose che
sono fondamentali per la nostra
sopravvivenza un pochino bisogno di pane
alla mano o poi se uno vuole magari per
qualcuno non è momento ci arriverà più
che in un tempo successivo però è una
cosa fondamentale
qua brescia stiamo provando a fare come
in tante altre parti d'italia come in
tante altre parti del mondo io negli
anni ho ho incontrato diversi modelli
uno di quelli che mi ha convinto di più
veloci che si chiama csa è un acronimo
sta per comunità che supporta
l'agricoltura e non è altro che un
tentativo di mettere a modello e mettere
a sistema per la riprogettazione del
territorio
quello che vi ho detto fino adesso cioè
il riprogettare le relazioni tra di noi
ci sono tanti modi per farlo appunto
andare in campo e fuori
abbiamo fatto tanti tipi di abbiamo
messo in campo diversi modi per poter
affrontare questo questo argomento
esiste già lo stiamo già facendo da mesi
il progetto si chiama rumor opoli qua a
brescia in questo caso giusto per
parlare qualcosa di pratico e abbiamo
pubblicato tutto abbiamo dichiarato come
stanno e cosa vogliamo fare in che
direzione andare ai modelli a cui ho
accennato prima perché in questo in
pochi minuti non posso far altro che
accennarvi di queste di queste
complessità che poi magari si possono si
possono concretizzare in una in una
cassetta una cassetta che deve riempire
le dispense e in una cassetta che è
fatta è composta da prodotti che vengono
da produttori che applicano quei modelli
posso garantire che in pochissimo tempo
se dovesse essere scelta da tante
persone cambierebbe molto velocemente
quanto meno iniziamo dall ambiente che
abbiamo circa circostante a noi
sostanzialmente anche perché non potrei
portarvi questa mattina 22 pomodori far
vedere ai visto che questo viene da
modelli e questo no perchè molto spesso
si assomigliano quello che è
profondamente diverso è quello che c'è
dentro e quello che c'è dietro per
arrivare ad averli
so che nella pausa pranzo vi aspetta vi
aspetta un pane che ha un valore
simbolico molto molto forte nei giri che
ho fatto ho incontrato tra i tanti ho
incontrato un progetto che che arriva da
quasi vent'anni di questo di questo
scambio di sinergie tra ricercatori e
scienziati genetisti associazioni
produttori agricoltori consumatori che
poi io preferisco chiamarli coproduttori
qual è la cosa meravigliosa di tutto
questo è che non hanno scelto una strada
bella bucolica perché qualcuno lei gli
influenzati gli ha proposto dire ma sì
dai perchè non proviamo a fare così
hanno dovuto fare delle cose che ero
completamente fuori dagli schemi nelle
loro vite personali dover fare degli
spostamenti essere guardati storti così
dall'amico ma che stai facendo sentirsi
dire ma si figurati tanto non sta in
piedi la concretezza qua a brescia poi
quante volte che ho sentite nella rete
si ma di ritirava linea se non c'è non
c'è il soldo fine mese sì tutto vero
però ci hanno creduto anche di fronte a
colossi dal punto di vista economico
ci hanno creduto hanno rotto gli schemi
hanno provato si sono messi in gioco e
non hanno scelto una strada l'hanno
costruita perché a volte non ci sono
bisogna costruirle grazie
buon appetito